To dig into this issue of similarity between a target problem and
a source case in different domains, let us look at another example.
Let us suppose it is a patient who has a tumor in his stomach.
There is a physician who has a laser gun. She knows that if the laser light were
to shine on this tumor, the tumor will be killed and the patient will be cured.
But the physician has a problem. The laser light is so
strong that it will also kill all the healthy tissue on its way to the tumor,
and thereby killing the patient. What should the physician do?
This is actually a very famous problem in cognitive science. It was first used
by a psychologist called Don Curry around 1926. What do you think
the physician should do in this situation? Take a moment and think about it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We'll return to the physician and
the patient example in just a minute. First let me tell you another story.
Once there was a kingdom ruled by a ruthless king, there was a rebel
army approaching the fortress in which the king lived. Well there was a problem.
The kings' men had mined, all the roads approaching the fort.
As a result, if an army was to walk over the roads, the mines would go off, and
the soldiers would be killed. So what did the army decide to do?
The army decided to decompose itself into smaller groups, so that each
group could come from a different road, and reach the fort at the same time.
Because each group was small enough, the mines on the roads did not go off.
The soldiers were able to attack the fort at the same time and
overthrow the bad king. Now let's go back to the problem of the physician and
the patient. What do you think now? Has the answer to the problem changed?
Some of you indeed may have changed your answer because of this story I
told you about the king and the rebel army. One solution to this problem is
that a physician would divide a very intense laser beam into several smaller,
less intense beams. As these beams come from different directions, they do
not harm the healthy tissue. However, they reach the tumor at the same time and
manage to kill the tumor. You will note that this is an example of
cross-domain analogy. Here the target problem had to do with the physician and
the patient. The source case had to do with the king and the rebel army.
The objects in these two situations were clearly very different.
In one case we had a physician and the patient, the laser beam and the tumor.
And in the other case we had the king and the rebel army, the fort and
the mines. Some of the relationships were very similar.
In capturing the fort case, we had a resource, the army, which was decomposed
into several small armies, which was sent to the goal location at the same time.
We took this battle, we took this strategy, abstracted it out,
and then applied it to the patient and physician example. A physician used
the same strategy. Resource decomposes into several smaller resources, and
sent to the goal at the same time. Now you can also see why the ant climbing
a wall is similar to a woman climbing a ladder. The objects are different,
ant and wall, woman, and ladder, but the relationship is similar. Climbing up.
The cross-domain analogy is then, the objects and the features and the values of
the objects can be different. The similarity is based on the relationship.
It is the relationship that is important. It is the relationship that
gets transferred from the source case to the target problem.